hi I'm getting that RSO and I'm going
undercover on the Internet
this is actually me I mean you may not
believe it but it's actually me Twitter
I haven't washed stranger things yet
please convince me well no matter how
old you are it's pretty much got
something for you if your kid it's a lot
of kids in it as teenagers is it
alternate there's a lot of cool
different themes there's romance horror
thriller comedy it's pretty much a love
letter to the 80s so if you like 80
cinema and 80 music your pop culture
clothing style I recommend you watch it
if you don't like it and that's too bad
submit Wikipedia dating John better as
of a third it's actually Caetano John
meta rise of the third began his career
on the Broadway stage as Benjamin and
Priscilla Queen of the desert
and this Gavroche his name is Rob those
are my two Broadway credits that I've
had before I did Lena is on Broadway I
did the national tour of limas also
playing Gavroche and I also did a
national tour of the Radio City
Christmas Spectacular then I was in the
Rockettes are and it's really cool and I
played a character net which is a lot of
fun also named Ben then seems to come up
a lot grease fans with yo dudes yeah I
did that for a while I wanted it to be
like a catchphrase thing and then I was
lying I don't need one of those then so
that's a little bit cheesy and campy any
time my mom posted my page she still
puts yo dudes like mom I don't say
anyone don't say that anymore mom cool
now hora what happened to Barbara is
stranger things
Barb's dead Barb's dead yeah she ain't
coming back
and I wanted to audition for a new
season of stranger things how would I go
about it I couldn't tell you I literally
have no clue um think that the most
important thing is to first get
representation I think that's really
important it was gonna be really hard to
get auditions or get jobs the whole
we're gonna go next
reddit
hey how kid-friendly is this show what
age would you consider appropriate I
don't consider a kid-friendly it's not
necessarily the scariest but there are
themes in it there's a lot of swearing
there are a little bit of adult
references there's some there's some
kissing boom YouTube but how did I study
I go to public school at home in New
Jersey I I'm so glad that I do when I'm
working like I am right now when I'm
when I'm off doing other things I have a
tutor and I make sure that I keep up
with my schoolwork at home but whenever
I'm home I'm always at public school I
think it's a great way to in keeps me
grounded and it keeps me in touch with
all my friends from home and it really
is great Instagram what are you doing is
that the cat you guys use some stranger
things this is my cat her name's
buttercup she's the love of my life the
Buttercup here is mainly like a white
coat and she's I believe she's having
food and a half American Shorthair and
Mews the cat is mainly all isn't all
orange tabby so it's a little bit
different you can put them side by side
and you'll you'll clearly see the
difference its gait and playing
instruments no I don't I started with
guitar for like a day and then I started
with piano for like a week I didn't
stick to him where can I find your music
it's neither on Spotify or Apple music
it's not will be eventually I hope one
of our song is 3 meter was playing on
the radio once which is cool it's really
really cool
Dustin is gonna die yeah even more
Twitter there's so much Twitter hashtag
stranger things
boiler theory they wouldn't notice
ademma Corgan toy hats you heads the
monster and 11 or 2 of the same well the
demagoguing has always had two heads in
not even the four Dungeons and Dragons
it's actually a character that's when
used and I believe a lot of Greek
mythology or Roman mythology and it's
come up a lot in different forms and I
think every time the demagogue has been
mentioned it has that duality about it a
troubled Muslim that doesn't want to do
bad and just ends up screwing things up
and then the counterpart which is
completely evil and destructive and
there's that those clashing minds and
maybe you
adds up to 11 being the the good and the
Devon working being the bad but I think
I think it was just a cool name from a
monster that was from D&D that they
liked that they the boys wanted to call
just it was familiar I wouldn't say it's
a spoiler or a theory I'd say that it's
probably just a cool thing to dwell
about I watched ET for the first time
last night does anyone else think it's a
total stranger things ripoff there's a
lot wrong with this question et's from
what 83 stranger Danis started in 2016
so uh no that wouldn't be possible it
definitely took inspiration there's a
lot more elements that I think are a lot
darker and different than iki but to say
that he's a ripoff of strangest things
that's true
that doesn't add up on a timeline of
life alright thanks Internet for all
your questions I hope you enjoyed the
video and I'll see you all soon
that's it y'all you